today I'm going to show you a cocktail
called the ambrosial swizzle that I
created for clever clubs summer menu it
is pure refreshment in a glass the
ingredient list sounds a little long but
trust me it is worth it
you need some white rum strawberries
cucumber vanilla the cure
pineapple juice a little bit of lime and
a little bit of simple syrup and a few
dashes of bitters so we're going to
start by muddling some strawberry and
cue cover and simple syrup I think it's
really important to muddle with just
simple syrup or whatever your sweetener
is for one because sugar is a great
conductor of flavor but also if you add
all your ingredients and then try to
muddle end up bobbing for cucumbers and
stronger so just crush it up nice and
easy now we can have the rest of our
ingredients a little bit fresh lime just
half an ounce 3/4 ounce of pineapple
juice fresh if you have it can works ok
to 2 ounces of white rum 3/4 of an ounce
of vanilla liqueur a few dashes of
bitters bitters are an infusion of herbs
roots and botanicals and I like to think
of them as a spice cabinet they're not
meant to be the primary flavor but
they're there to enhance it so you just
need a little bit just a few dashes
alright so now we can shake this to be a
quick shake a couple of seconds we're
going to strain the string do a highball
or tall glass we're going to strain it
over cracked or crushed ice
so it'll melt a little faster so the
reason we didn't shake this drink very
long is because we're also going to
swizzle it a little bit with a bar spoon
swizzle is an alternative way to chill
down a cocktail it's very common in
tropical drinks you just rub your hands
together to move a spoon kind of like
you're building a campfire with sticks
it helps to dilute the ice and chill
your drink down alright finally slice a
cucumber it's a garnish there's a
regular at the bar that loves this drink
and he'll come in and say to me I need
to cool off and that's basically his
code for ordering and ambrosia swizzle
so the next time you find the heat
getting to you keep this drink in mind
if you liked this video and you're
looking for more tips to step up your
bartending game subscribe to the GQ
channel about lots more where that came
from